Joe Biden finally popping the giant
Chinese spy balloon but did it take too
long for it to go boom after letting it
fly over most of the continental U.S the
military finally shooting this sucker
down off the coast of South Carolina
the president just a little while ago
says it was always his plan to take it
out
it made it clear to China what we're
going to do they understand our position
we're not going to back off we did the
right thing has it always been your view
to shoot down a Chinese five balloon
balloon or was it only because it became
public oh no it was always my position
once it came over the United in the
United States from Canada I told the
defense department wanted to shoot us
down as soon as it was appropriate They
concluded They concluded we should not
shoot it down over land was not a
serious threat and we should wait till
we got across the water
clearly this is his finest moment since
Corn Pop parts of this Kami spycraft
have been scooped up and sent over to
the FBI for further analysis and despite
assuring the American people there was
no threat a senior U.S official now says
there may have been self-detonating
explosives explosives on the vessel just
like Jesse's hair Republicans are
reacting with their usual pouncing
the message they were trying to send is
what they believe internally and that is
that the United States is a once great
superpower that's hollowed out that's in
Decline and the message they're trying
to send the world is look these guys
can't even do anything about a balloon
flying over U.S airspace but a spy
balloon complete its spy mission before
we shot it down I I'm afraid is an
embarrassment to the United States the
president taking it down over the
Atlantic is sort of like the quarterback
it's sort of like tackling the
quarterback after the game is over it
makes us look weak and flat-footed on
the world stage
and China is pushing back against
America claiming what happened is a
quote clear overreaction and you can
probably guess who agrees with that
they love this
and through this big drama if you're
going to spy you're not going to send a
giant balloon all across the United
States for a week right I mean Chinese
know how to spy they you know they can
do it better they wanted to create a
crisis a national crisis an
international crisis they wanted it to
be elevated and it would be visible and
be talked about and they got it
Dana to be fair if you're looking for
experts on giant balloons you got to go
to the view I'm
just my go-to yeah exactly and for
foreign policy yeah for foreign policy
everything could be handled better
that's good you could say that about
anything uh what do you make of this and
you're sober objective criticism I think
hindsight is 20 20 right but did you
just coined that yeah I mean it's a
really good phrase if you think about it
if you think like if hindsight when you
look back yes things are always perfect
a few things to raise so Bloomberg
reported that President Biden was
keeping it quiet because he didn't want
to give Republicans any fodder
for suggesting he's weak on China
I do think that if they had shot it down
over Alaska to come down there would
have been criticism of why did you shoot
it down so quickly you should have let
it blah blah blah I mean there's a lot
of sort of
uh Point Counterpoint on that however
because they kept it quiet they ensured
that there would be more mystery now
that there's more mystery there are a
lot more questions including this thing
where over the weekend the
administration from the Pentagon floats
this thing that says three of these
balloons came across during the Trump
Administration well that story all fell
apart pretty quickly because it's like
what do you mean by near everybody in
the Trump Administration including the
former president himself and everybody
that was in National Security said no I
don't think so so now the president is
just hanging out there by himself and if
you think there's all the criticism is
one thing this is a moment where
President Biden could have said let's
all rally together let's all do this
together I mean this is tomorrow night
is going to talk about the state of the
union we can all agree that this is not
acceptable we could all do that but
instead because they try to keep it
quiet it was never going to be kept
quiet then they tried to basically blame
president Trump or like try to solely
Trump over this that invited all these
other conversations rather than just
saying we are United against China and
stay tuned for Tuesday night I'm going
to tell you more yeah you know Jessica
it does seem that we should all be
pointing fingers at China instead of
each other but having said that is it
fair to say that Joe is The Manchurian
Candidate under the thumb of the CCP
that's actually what I was going to lead
with
red
I was trying to be nice and she's
wearing blue so let's see where that's
going when she could talk
um
so this was really I was thinking about
the last time that there was kind of
foreign policy outrage over what Joe
Biden did and Afghanistan is obviously
the big
the kind of motherload of everybody is
criticizing him and it that particular
instance it was he really wanted that
right and the military the Pentagon and
all the generals were saying we need to
do this at a slower rate you can't just
pull everyone out of there we're going
to be leaving people behind we're going
to lose lives because of it we created a
civil society there that's in tatters at
this point I mean horrific stories of
what's coming out there this wasn't that
right so Biden's first reaction which is
perfectly in line with his personality
was shoot it down in the leg
it's funny
um shoot it down and the Pentagon said
that's not what's safest and can I can
you imagine what would happen if
suddenly there were explosive devices or
if there was another let's for uh those
who think it that kovid was a bio weapon
right that leaked out of this plant in
lab and Wuhan and there was something
like that in the balloon we had no idea
what was going on there and that would
have been so much astronomically worse
than what happened so yes of course a
few days of people able to see this
thing and take pictures of it on their
iPhones is obviously a problem and we'll
hear more about the previous balloons
that apparently our technology couldn't
even track properly which speaks badly
of us right if they have been floating
these balloons even over Alaska which
last time I checked was ours we should
know about it every single time that
that happens but I don't see how this is
some major flaw in the Biden foreign
policy apparatus or some major point of
embarrassment and I think that when
people jock you for points with
something like this it kind of Hollows
out more valid arguments that they might
make of where he has fallen short like
in Afghanistan Jesse she makes a valid
argument there care to retort sure
so this thing flew across the entire
country and got nothing
it didn't spy on anything they never
picked up any in touch well that's what
Joe Biden's saying Joe Biden's saying
this thing came 4 500 miles across the
continental United States and trust me
it didn't pick up anything that's the
same thing they said about the woman
that slept with small well she didn't
really get much Dianne Feinstein's
driver was a Chinese spy for twins it
didn't really hear much in the back seat
they say that every time about China I
don't trust that these Chinese guys are
in Beijing with a little joystick if
they're not picking up anything then why
are they zigzagging the balloon over all
of our military bases well Joe says he
took counter measures it's like when
Jesse Jr tries to hide in the living
room he takes a blanket he just throws
him where is Jesse I don't know
peek-a-boo that's Joe Biden how many
times has the United States government
says we've taken counter measures to
make sure the Chinese don't steal our
stuff they've been saying that for three
decades but they keep stealing our stuff
so I'm not taking Joe's word for it
maybe we did black out the military
bases what if they flew over General
Electric's headquarters caterpillars
headquarters Berkshire Hathaway's
headquarters
do they have the counter measures that
the defense department has did Warren
Buffett throw a blanket over his hard
drive up they got nothing so I'm not
really trusting what they're telling us
now imagine this happens with Trump
imagine the Chinese send six million
dollars to the Trump family the Chinese
send 100 million dollars to the Trump
Center at Penn and then give Don Jr a
few diamonds
and then Trump lies all about it tries
to cover it up and the Chinese float a
spy device all over and he doesn't touch
the thing until after it spies on us and
shoots it out of the sky they would
impeach in a second
Montana
has no one living in Montana Alaska
even less people
you know how the radius was to pick up
this thing that fell into the ocean
seven miles you're saying you couldn't
find a seven square mile area in Alaska
or Montana to recover this thing last
time I checked too when Electronics get
wet they fizzle out
when it lands on land they probably
survive better it's almost like Joe
Biden wanted the balloon sack to get wet
and the Pentagon it's almost like he
wanted it to get wet so the FBI takes it
so the FBI now has the laptop and it has
the Chinese balloon sack in Quantico
they're analyzing both
the best part about this is that Joe is
overruled by the generals Joe said shoot
it down and the general said let's wait
yeah right right let's wait right judge
that's a great this is this is the
latest act by China in terms of
Espionage and spying on the United
States and if we look at it any
differently than that than we are being
naive whether it was those Confucius
institutes at the colleges whether it's
their hacking into a hundred American
country companies with the backing of
the Chinese Communist Party whether it's
Tick-Tock the honey pots it's a constant
effort by China to sabotage the United
States and but for those reporters in
Montana that we found out about we would
never have known about this and I give
you as evidence of that the fact that
Biden had no intention of pulling
blinken back from going to China Lincoln
wasn't pulled back until Friday when
Biden apparently knew in the
administration knew on Saturday but all
no once the American people knew he's
I'm going to be tough I'm not going to
have blink and go over there hogwash we
just called your bluff now China says
initially it was a meteorological
surveillance and the U.S was good with
that there's no problem the other just
doing climate checking climate stuff and
so they the white house then says they
didn't get much of anything well how the
hell do you know that and what are they
doing hovering above our
intercontinental ballistic missile sites
and I understand for military people
that they can actually see the lay of
the airplanes underground in those
missile sites and here's another one for
you for those why the balloons the
balloons fly above aircraft they fly 60
80 100
000 feet above ground what does that
tell you that level of height doesn't
permit the shooting of it down in other
words in F-22 cannot take down one of
these it's not a damn balloon from a
birthday party it's a spycraft an F-22
cannot take it down if it's 60 80 000 or
100 000 feet up so what we've got is
them hovering over Montana our
intercontinental ballistic sites and
Biden then says the military said no no
don't take it down hogwash if we learned
anything from Biden and Afghanistan it's
at the top generals when they were put
under oath said we told Biden you got to
leave people there we tow Biden you have
to leave people in in Afghanistan and
Biden said no they never told me they
never warned me the bottom line is this
when Kareem Jean-Pierre gets up today
and she says well it's up to China to
decide what the relationship is that's
naive it is up to us to set the
parameters and to say you have violated
our sovereignty you have breached our
security there's going to be
consequences but not with this guy AI
all right
great start for a Monday huh here we go
I think we could probably just go home
yeah let's go home yeah yeah I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now